je me permets de vous contredire sur sur
deux petits points d'abord sur l'idée de
parallèles entre les contraventions d'un
côté les poursuites pénales contre les
dirigeants de l'autre moi je vois pas
bien entre ces deux aspects là il y
avait une espèce de nécessité foncière
c'était je pense très mal fait et très
mal formulée très mal écrit ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'on peut dire de nos
jours que des textes des normes
juridiques loi ou pas son centre est mal
écrit mais le jeu ne fait pas parallèles
entre les deux si vous voulez et je
crois pas qu'ils aient des poursuites
qu'ils soient engagées ou à venir contre
les politiques contre les responsables
parce que beaucoup de contraventions
contre les citoyens j'arrive pas
intellectuellement à connecter les
autres d'autre part dit condamner jamais
perdre balisé de personnes qui
continuent à faire l'amour sans
préservatif avec le sida c'est tout à
fait faux mais si je peux me permettre
parce que alors à l'époque ça n'aurait
pas du tout constituer une contravention
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de texte mais
et je reviens à l'exemple que je citais
tout à l'heure je regrette de pas
pouvoir dans une meilleure acuité
mémorielle et voulu dire plus
précisément des personnes qui avaient
connaissance de leur séropositivité et
qui ont continué à avoir des
comportements notamment sexuelle ne
saurait peut être les seringue aussi de
nature à transmettre le virus ont été
poursuivies et elles ont été poursuivies
si mon souvenir est exact en cour
d'assises pourquoi parce que là aussi
une grande différence entre le virus du
sida et le virus le cofide 19 et c'est
une différence qui à mon avis y aura une
grande importance dans l'appréciation
des poursuites c'est qu'il y en a un qui
est mortelle de façon quasi systématique
c'est simple c'était malheureusement à
l'époque y avait pas les traiter rapide
simple question de temps
et aujourd'hui le coc u19 c'est mortel
dans une une proportion qui heureusement
était extrêmement faible et donc quand
vous allez vouloir poursuivre quelqu'un
pour homicide involontaire pour avoir
transmis le virus du duc ovine 19 vous
aller buter sur quelque chose parce que
peut-être on va dire vous êtes
asymptomatiques ou vous avez quinze
jours de fièvre et ça s'est arrêté là
[Musique]